president trump
just showed up to the world series
and one of the memes that's going around
the world series one of the memes that
goes around the braves
is the chop
you know sort of indian chop so the
braves fans were doing this and
president trump joined in on the fun
i love they're all doing it and there's
trump there right in his box
doing the you can hear people down below
is that mark meadows yet is you can hear
people down below he's doing it too look
he's doing it too
so the left can't do this they're not
allowed
to do this
okay and we can why isn't the left
allowed to do because they would be told
this is racist
this is racist to
do a thing that is associated with
indian culture you can't do that it's
the braves and you're not you can't
trump is not from georgia
i don't think trump even likes georgia
that much because he thinks that georgia
was rigged and
took the election away from him trump's
a new yorker so why is he there rooting
for the braves because the braves
are
they're the politically incorrect team
right now they've got the politically
incorrect name they're in georgia which
which has those politically incorrect
laws
pro-life laws all sorts of laws and
that's why mlb took the all-star game
out of georgia but now they've got to go
back for the world series that's
hilarious
and so we get to smile and laugh and
have fun and do the the indian shop
why because we're not the ones taking
away people's baseball
and teams
and culture
and fun
we're not the ones doing that we
conservatives are saying no you should
have your baseball teams and the names
and you should have your fun and you
should have your culture and you can
wear a sombrero on cinco de mayo and you
should be able to wave the american flag
and you should be able to have your
families and you should be able to make
jokes and you should be able to have
your country
and the left is saying no your country
is evil
it's awful
especially if you're a white or a man or
straight you're really bad
and so they're they're this party of
scolds
and the right is having fun now it's
it's unfortunate in a way because the
reason we're having fun is because we're
not ruling we're not in power right now
but that does that that is a kind of
power in and of itself the power to
weaken the regime to criticize it to get
a lot of other people around to
criticize it that
is
helpful it's almost undeniable at this
point
that the left is the ruling power in
this country hey there youtube
ring that bell please please i i want to
be polite please ring the bell subscribe
theoretically you should get
notifications when you do that you
probably still won't but that's that's
okay that's fine you can also go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five star
review
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]